okay the only problem is
they're dealing with the problem on a
level a thousand times bigger here to
explain more texas governor greg abbott
this you know it's funny the muriel
bowser said she wanted the national
guard called up because you rightly said
okay
you if joe biden
wants illegal immigrants and he's going
to aid in a bet in the law breaking he
can take care of the people that he
bring allows into the country illegally
and so you're sending them to washington
d.c i want every red state governor to
follow your lead and when planes drop
off illegal immigrants put them in buses
and send them to 1600 pennsylvania
avenue i think that that
joe's problem he caused it he aided it
why not handle it i think everyone
should do it
exactly right and believe me we have
more buses ahead of their way as we
speak right now
but sean this just shows the hypocrisy
of these liberal leaders up in the
northeast who think well that border
cross is created by joe biden that's
fine as long as it's texas that has to
deal with it but as soon as they have to
deal with the real consequences of
biden's border cause crisis they're up
in arms calling for the national guard
as you point out dealing with just a
tiny fraction of what we have to deal
with every single day
we're going to keep sending those buses
up there until they fully understand and
most importantly sean until the
administration does its job to enforce
the laws concerning the border
right so you got their attention and i
hope that everybody follows suit because
honestly you've been dealing with this
in in massive record numbers every
single month and it's it literally has
overwhelmed your state
and at this point if joe biden continues
not to enforce the laws of the land i
don't think you really have any choice
because i don't think the state of texas
ought to bear the brunt of his bad
policies and i think i i think that was
the right move now
uh are you getting more and more buses
are you going to send more and more
people
so because of the increased influx of
people coming into our state and because
what the border patrol is doing they're
just processing the paperwork of these
people coming here illegally and then
dumping off these immigrants into our
small local communities
we are helping out these small local
communities by sending even more buses
to these communities and putting these
new migrants on the buses and sending
them to washington d.c and
we're looking at other cities to send
them to well new york sounds like a good
one i don't i try and stay as far away
from the city i get in the car i go in a
building i get back in the car and i go
home that's it
governor great job as always and we're
going to follow this really closely also
your re-election is pivotal uh i know
you're not going to have a hard race but
with that said i never take any election
for granted and you've done a great job
for the people of texas governor thank
you hey sean hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else